hey what's up guys my name is Samuel
Leeds I'm a property investor I make a
lot of money property investing and I
also like to help other people also
invest successfully in property so one
of the things that I do I do a video
every single day but on a Sunday I do a
weekly Q&A where i answer all your
property questions your niggly property
related questions I ask them best I can
and this week we've got some seriously
good questions from last week so I'm
going to start answering these now but
here's the thing if you've got a
property question please do comment
below I'd love to read it I'd love to
try and answer it next week also while
I'm answering these questions if it
triggers another question calling it
below get commenting also if you haven't
already subscribed to this channel
please do go ahead and subscribe don't
forget to hit that notification bell so
you never miss a video because they're
pretty good and let's see we've got this
week so James Sneden thank you so much
James sinan for commenting you the man
he said so I'm a big fan of your videos
I've been stuck in a rat race for a long
time and I'm looking to get out question
is if you're aware of an area that's
having a lot of new infrastructure ie
new roads being built in due to
congestion and new retail park being
built would it be a smart move to
potentially invest in property around
that area
what I would say is the thing you've got
to be really careful of James is buying
for potential future capital growth you
know what you want to be buying for is
you want to be buying for good cash flow
so all areas are being developed all the
time in England pretty much so while a
retail park is kind of cool and I'm sure
it's gonna I'm sure it's going to lift
the area don't get don't get super hung
up on you know what might happen in the
future because you never really know so
is it going to be making money
immediately is it going to be giving you
a good return on investment these are
the things I've been looking for also if
you want to get capital appreciation
capital growth you want to make sure
that you buy after a recession and
people think that there's just a
recession and an expansion either or but
that's not the case you've seen some
cities there could be an expansion going
on whilst in other cities just an hour
down the road there's a recession going
on because that's how it works because
the each each city is kind of almost got
its own
it's own economy so you want to find an
area where properties have just gone
through a recession and then most people
are scared and as Warren Buffett says
when they're scared that's when you be
greedy and you buy when properties are
low by low rent high with a property
manager nearby that's kind of my
philosophy so I hope that's helpful
again if you've got more questions off
of the back of that comment them below
all come on down to the property
investors crash course two days where we
work out how to find a good property on
the spot and do it over the two days and
it's free as well I'll put a link in the
description below
perhaps what else we got next is having
three houses for rent
is it better to open a limited company
or just declare income from the property
and no limited company okay so if you
just bought a few houses should you set
up a limited company to buy those houses
I think is the question if you already
own them I wouldn't set up a limited
company and try and move them into a
company because by the time you to pay
your stamp duty your accountancy fees it
just isn't worth doing so what I would
say is if you're if you already own the
properties just leave them as they are
leave them in your individual name I do
recommend from in my experience speak to
an accountant for bespoke advice because
I can't give financial advice bespoke
one-on-one on the video like this when
my experience buying through a limited
company is better because there's tax a
lot of tax savings so you can claim the
mortgage payments as tax deductible when
you buy for a company so I buy through a
company if you're going to be doing this
seriously as a business and buying a lot
of houses it probably is going to be
more tax efficient to buy through a
company so I Germany I would advise that
okay Matt backs I think I've answered
Matt Beck's questions before I love your
questions broke you comment in them
every week so Matt beck says what are
the obvious signs that a particular area
is getting saturated with investors okay
really interesting listen if an area
saturated with investors it doesn't
necessarily mean it's a bad area to
invest because I'd rather buy in an area
where everyone's investing in the area
because they're probably investing in
the area because it's good then go into
an area like in some weird part
wails when nothing's going on and then
you're like ha no one's doing it
no one's doing it because it sucks so if
an area is oversaturated it doesn't
necessarily mean it's bad what you
normally want to do is you normally want
to do something just a little bit
different so let's say if everyone's
buying HMOs in Birmingham and it's like
oh it's in loads of HMOs in Birmingham
probably the supply is great meaning
lots of people are doing it there's lots
of supply probably the demand is also
great so it's a case of how can I buy
something in the area I know the demands
gray and stand out from the competition
and make the supply a little different
maybe it's a case of I'm gonna put on
sweets in my rooms because there's loads
of rooms available but there's not many
on sweets so make sure that you've got
an area where the demand is high the
supply is probably going to be high too
unless no one's caught on done but
normally they do cotton on it just make
your product a little bit different
that's what I want to say so how do you
know if it's oversaturated again you can
do market research you can you can you
can check out really agents in the area
see how fast properties are going see
what's selling go on Rightmove and see
what's sold recently and what's
available so you can definitely do your
research but that's my overall advice so
next is from Sandra Sandra says has
article 4 stopped or restricted you from
doing HMOs maybe influenced your choice
of investment strategy or do you still
buy properties for hatre my purposes and
pay the license fees license fees okay
so article 4 does not affect the license
fees whatsoever what article 4 does is
it means that you can't buy a single out
house article for a district like a zone
that the council's put into areas you
can't buy a single that house and turn
it into a hay chamo without planning
permission licensing HMO is a separate
thing
planning licensing is easy piling
permission can be a bit of a pain so how
is it affecting my strategy so if an or
I personally don't buy houses and turn
them into HMOs when they're in an
article for
because it's too expensive it's too
time-consuming and it's too high-risk
because you might not get the planning
so what I do is I find areas that are
not article 4 but up going to become
arty before I buy a single at house turn
it into a HMO and then when article 4
comes in I have the grandfather rights
the automatic planning permission which
then what that does is it kills off my
competition and it usually in time will
increase the value with the house and it
means that I haven't got to bother
getting planning permission and got the
cost the hassle or the risk of having to
get planning permission so that's what I
do all oh you you could buy an existing
HMO which already has got planning
permission but the pond with that is
you're going to pay a premium for that
so that what I've said is what I do not
just say it's the one and only thing has
to benefit from article 4 but that's
what I'm doing and I hope that helps you
ok next question from Chris burgers hi
say I'm in a good situation but don't
know how to make the most of it we've
got a place in London and there's quite
a bit of equity we've been renting out
for the past few years but didn't change
the mortgage to buy to let the tenants
have now moved out and we're looking for
more we want to release the equity
should we change the mortgage to buy to
let it will increase our mortgage
payments and we'll eat into the profit
but it will give us more of a chance
that bank or lend us the money I work in
the film industry and a freelance
photographer but there are gaps in my
employment so not good to release as a
residential Oh juicy question Chris okay
so Chris if you're going to rent out it
really does need to be on a buy to let
mortgage because if you're renting it
out as a residential mortgage that is
technically mortgage fraud so if you got
caught doing that you're not going to
get like putting prison or anything
crazy like that but they're not going to
be happy and they're probably going to
slap you on the knuckles and and force
you to switch the switch over to buy to
that worst case is they could make you
pay off the mortgage and blacklist you
so so definitely wouldn't advise renting
out as a residential so what would I
suggest that you do okay do you know
what I would do I would sell it I would
sell that place because the fact that
you're saying if you switch it to buy
two lettuce can eat have your profit
it's going to become not that profitable
I mean jeez Yuri I don't suggest
generally selling houses the only time I
would sell a house is if the house isn't
making me much money and could make me
more money if I put the money elsewhere
so the father you're not living in any
way of course I'd have to know the exact
figures but my guess is that you're
going to be much better off if you just
sell the place and then with all the
money you buy one or even you you you
buy more than one I don't know how much
money you're going to get for this
property but that's what I would
probably be inclined to say to do if
you're getting bites to layer of course
the lender who's not so interested in
your income so the fact that you're a
freelance videographer or photographer
is probably going to be an issue that
will be my gut feeling however I'd love
you to come down to the property
investors crash course if you haven't
already because you need to know what to
do with the money once you've sold the
house if you don't want to sell the
house and you think the property is
fantastic then just switch over to a buy
to let mortgage and just accept that
you're going to be making a little bit
less monthly income than you are if you
did as a residential hope that helps man
alright last question now it's two more
going to more Joshua says good evening
Samuel good evening Joshua I have a
burning question how does one
financially protect their property
assets do you protect your property
assets in a trust or do you go elsewhere
okay my suggestion respectfully Joshua
is that you don't ask that question
until you got some serious assets first
maybe you already do have assets maybe
you're a multi multi-millionaire I don't
know but I wouldn't worry about how to
protect and say until you've got the
money like sometimes people let the tail
wag the dog and they think how am I
gonna save money on tax
I'm gonna protect and all that stuff but
you know ultimately you're just going to
sit down with we have an asset
protection manager and an accountant and
get to pick their brains but there's no
point paying them right now if you
haven't got the well so go get the
wealth go make the money and then focus
on how to protect it to set up a company
though if you've got a company if you're
running a business trading business it's
better through a company there's an
individual for tax reasons but also for
protection because if someone Sue's you
they're suing the company not you
personally so your assets and your
wealth is protected but I really
wouldn't spend more than about thirty
five seconds thinking about this and
we've probably spent thirty five seconds
already talking about it so now it's
suggest that you spend the next thirty
five months going and creating wealth
and then we can spend another thirty
five seconds talking but uh go go make
some money man and then we'll protect it
alright last question guy pen now how
important is modern-day education in
running a successful property business I
don't know what modern-day education
means I mean if you mean formal
education ie University I don't think
it's important at all in fact modern-day
formal education I a schools the
education system universities they teach
you to be poor so I know you do I think
that they're unimportant as you think
that they're damaging to you as an
entrepreneur because they train you to
be to be poor because the banks and the
education system they want you to be
poor and I can prove this in other
videos but I don't think that's it'd be
quite your answering your question so
but if you mean by modern education you
mean self education and you mean like my
training programs I guess is that modern
to education that's really important Jim
Rohn says that formal education will
make you a living but self education
will make you a fortune so self
education all the way and modern-day
education I don't know I mean I like to
study history history of economics it
depends on what you want to get
it depends if you want to be rich that's
different too if you want to be you want
to be a doctor or a hairdresser so it's
a broad question but if you want to be
rich then you've got to do self
education
I'd suggest starting by some of my
training programs in fact we've run a
2-day property investors crash course I
mentioned I think I did already on this
video I'm gonna leave the link below in
the description with an invitation for
you guys to come and join me at the
two-day property investors crash course
on the house costs me thousands of
pounds to put these and programs on on
the house why am i doing that on the
house why would I run it for free and
put this program on for free number one
because your success is my oxygen and I
want I'm on a mission to help as many
people become financially free as
possible number two is I know that I
believe in good karma and I believe that
when you give a lot of value than money
fires so as a result of my training
programs I get a lot of joint venture
partners I get a lot of advanced
students and what goes around comes
around so get yourself booked on the
program link below stop thinking about
it do it and I look forward to working
with you guys real soon please don't
forget to smash the like button if you
enjoyed the video hit the subscribe
button hit the notification bell bit and
drop a comment below I look forward to
getting to know you and seeing you on
the next video thank you so much peace
out
[Music]